what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
so we are continuing on with fear itself
and uh yeah feared it is a really cool
story it is a pretty badass story in
this point we pick up with journey into
mystery now those you guys who don't
know journey into mystery originally it
was like a scientist sci-fi story it was
a series of like you know science
fiction mystery comics whatever and then
thor appear and then thor was so popular
that eventually journey into mystery
became a thor line of comics for the
most parts when journey into mystery was
brought back
it basically revolved around loki and
the reason for that again came out of
siege and this is part of the things
that we've talked about in the past
where we've said that marvel does soft
reboots which is to say they shuffle up
a character if they change status quo
but they don't do hard line reboot
despite the fact they need to aah in
this instance what ended up happening is
that during the events of siege on
Asgard in thor issue number 617 which
was actually part of the aftermath to
siege we ended up discovering that what
loki had done is he had gone to hella
who was basically the ruler of the
Asgardian afterlife and it essentially
like bartered things so that he could
basically return to life when his
physical form died and so what ended up
happening after this was that in thor
6:17 loki came back but he was a little
kid and he had no knowledge of anything
he had done when he was an adult he was
basically a blank slate so again it was
pretty smart and it was a pretty genius
idea in terms of trying to rework his
character kid loki is actually pretty
cool namely loki has discovered the
internet and it is interesting he's
basically taking pictures of all these
crazy things happening around like
Asgard and people are just like that's
not like like you had to have used a
lens filter because obviously he's using
Instagram but anyway one of the other
things to notice here is that Loki's
basically being ridiculed by one of the
other as Guardians and this was par for
the course people remember him as the
trickster the bad guy the one that's
essentially brought nothing but ruin and
pain upon Asgard itself but for Thor one
thing to remember is Loki is his brother
and Thor really sees this version of kid
Loki for what he is he's not really
blinded by the things Loki's done in the
past and so the result is that he kind
of chases a few of these bullies off and
basically says hey look this is kind of
how these things go eventually it'll
pass and so it's kind of interesting
here because Loki's saying stuff like
like when you discover the internet he's
saying stuff like I told people I was an
Asgardian and they started calling me a
troll like nobody on the internet
believes me and and and to me it's it's
such an awesome exchange right you know
cuz Thor's kinda like whoa I mean oh you
know Loki is I am aware of the internet
and we avoid it avidly because people on
the Internet are weird like
I mean not really but it's just kind of
a funny thing you know like I like the
idea of kid loci discovering the
Internet but the fact remains here that
what Loki ends up doing is stumbling
upon this this magpie this bird and as
soon as he approaches it that thing
explodes and reveals a key and this is
why journey into mystery is so cool is
because when you look at traditional
Thor stories which is to say basically
everything after journey into mystery
and especially going from really the the
Bronze Age from like the mid 1970s up to
the modern day Thor stories are pretty
straightforward it's just like Thor
spotting a bad guy and smashing things
with his hammer because that's what he
does and that's what you want to see but
with journey into mystery the way this
is done is a throwback to the old
journey into mystery stories where it
was as much about like the history and
mythos of Asgard and telling stories in
an Asgardian fashion as it was about
events unfolding in a way that was
interesting and so in this journey that
Loki goes on he discovers this key takes
it to what's basically kind of an elf of
sorts who and starts singing off this
poem loi Loki listens to it realizes
part of the poem is a location he
travels there awakens a demon which
immediately explodes feeds the demon to
Volstagg and then listens to what
Volstagg says which is kind of a wry or
really kind of a few words of sorts
follows the the advices given to him in
the sense that it's like the the third
passage or so on and so forth discovers
a dragon which basically explodes in
front of him kind of disintegrates and
then like speedily at least it speaks to
him in the old tongue first then it
disintegrates and then he starts
basically following these these sage
bits he reads his little hash that says
that loki went into the void and no one
knows why and that's when he falls down
into this darker place and discovers the
older version of himself
this is classic journey into mystery
Thor storytelling so meeting with his
older self this older version of Loki
basically says look like I am here to
impart wisdom on you and I'm the reason
why you exist basically I had barter
with hell everything that we said at the
beginning of the video and the idea was
that I would be reborn in a new physical
form now this is important because this
is not really the spirit of older Loki
it's more of like a memory echo but this
is kind of an important thing because
over the course of the journey into
mystery lon which we may or may not
cover there will be points when kid Loki
will meet with his older self and
there's actually points in in the modern
Thor storytelling where Loki where kid
Loki will not only meet with his older
self he'll actually meet with a female
version of himself and in the modern day
look you will meet with kid Loki and the
female version and his original self so
there's is really one of these things
where because of the steps that Loki's
taken to ensure his own existence very
like Voldemort in the Horcruxes what
this means is that there are sort of
echoes of himself that exist out there
in the Marvel landscape which can be
encountered by anyone whose versions at
any particular point in time
assuming that echo has already been
created but as basically him saying look
like I have sage advice to give you I
have bits of knowledge to give you you
have to listen to this because there is
a crisis coming to Earth and to Asgard
of course we know that older Loki is
speaking of speaking of the serpent and
these are important things to remember
because by and large Loki was always
considered to be the trickster and the
guy who created mischief and that's true
but because of his experiences in
traveling around the various cosmos
because of his experience and seeing and
doing all these things what this means
is that Loki has a vast amount of
knowledge some of which is based on
things he's not supposed to know and so
because of all this he's a very very
huge resource if you can find a way to
tap into that without incurring his
wrath or her you know letting him trick
you or something along those lines and
that's what happens with kid Loki and
it's kind of a cool thing because this
is really Marvel saying like Loki as
Loki as Loki is located it'll always end
up being the same all of this has
happened before and all of it'll happen
again to quote Battlestar Galactica that
all roads lead to Rome that no matter
how many times Loki's reborn how many
how many no matter how many times he
returns to his former self
he will always in becoming the Loki that
we always know because that's what his
character is that's what he's about and
so what this story does is it basically
segues into the the tale bit of as ago
I'm sorry of fear itself that we covered
in the last video we're essentially like
leads the Asgardians out of out of earth
and takes them directly to take you
directly back to Asgard to the Asgardian
dimension where they can essentially go
through and start recreating everything
now at this point we kind of switch over
to the aftermath right like to when
they're actually in Asgard itself and
remember like this is this place is just
in shambles I mean it's been this way
ever since Ragnarok it's been distorted
pieces now again it's entirely within
the power of Odin to fix it all and
that's really what he says but notice
this not everyone agrees with what Odin
does and that's one of the
misconceptions a lot of people I think
have when it comes to the Thor mythos is
a lot of people look at the character of
Odin and they say well he's the
all-father he's a leader of course they
all follow him Loki and Thor are the
only ones that really kind of do what
they want not true
just because Odin is the all-father and
the leader does not mean everyone agrees
with what he does the difference here is
that Odin has enough power to obliterate
anybody and he pretty much will and so
because of this Thor basically speaks up
when a couple people start talking about
how it feels like a retreat Thor says
that's because it is because the power
that's there on earth whatever this
serpent is is enough that it scares Odin
and Odin is essentially running away
and so we're thort questions as fathers
authority where he calls him in and and
says look you're essentially a coward is
what you are like you're a weakling our
job is to protect all nine of the realms
you are hiding in your in your home
waiting for the threat to come to you
you are every ounce that cower that
you're acting as then Odin immediately
has him locked up immediately has Thor
like take it away and put in Chains and
so at this point this is when we start
getting into the idea of the worthy
those individuals out there who are
given these secret Asgardian hammers and
the first one up is juggernaut so uh but
what is up happening is of course you
have juggernaut going through his
workout time seven minutes is really all
he gets
and then he then like while all this is
going on a hammer crash lands into into
the prison and of course this is one of
the things that you they you end up
finding out those individuals who are
worthy the hammer will speak to them
they'll just hear words voices things
like that emanating from the hammer
itself and so when juggernaut picks it
up he basically ends up becoming curse
the breaker of stone now again this idea
of juggernaut gaining another power
source in addition to what he has will
be a major plot point when it comes to
this story this is something I want you
to keep in the back of your head as we
go further through the fear of self
event but juggernaut what this power is
is immense I mean he just starts
smashing everything in his path and so
what ends up happening is we switch over
directly to Steve Rogers to Captain
America to Maria Hill to Sharon Carter
and it's basically like the New Avengers
roster combined with what passes for
what's left of the Thunderbolts and is
essentially this idea that like all this
pandemonium and chaos is happening
around the world that these objects are
crash landing now in response to them
landing various places around the world
major metropolitan areas are turning
into absolute madhouse as things are
completely and totally going awry and so
Reed Richards charms in as part of the
Future Foundation remember this comes
after Hickman's Fantastic Four so the
future foundation has already been
formed by that point but reach arms in
as a future foundation it says look a
hammer or something like that has
crash-landed and New York we're studying
it at the moment but it looks like it's
as you know it's from its of Asgardian
nature so this thing looks pretty
intense and then we switch over to the
one thing everybody wants to see the
Incredible Hulk
this is what is the coolest thing is
what I love about you guys everybody
loves the Incredible Hulk
what people love even more is when the
Incredible Hulk gets something that
modifies his power what they love more
than that is when he gets somebody
else's power source specifically when he
gets an Asgardian hammer people love
that kind of stuff but this basically
takes place after the events of Greg
packs run and really kind of the
finality of that event you know from
from heart of the monster hole and we
saw from that story that it picked up we
really ended with like The Incredible
Hulk Bruce Banner and Betty Ross red
she-hulk just kind of jumping out and
doing doing what they do in the heat of
passion and so they're just kind of
there doing their thing but while all
this is going on a hammer basically
lands and The Incredible Hulk sort of
listens to it here's a talking and then
against Betty Ross protest goes to pick
it up and when he does he turns into
like the most badass looking character
now it is not an accident for why he
looks this way while this is a totally
new design for him it does have some
hints and homages to the time when he
basically became a horseman for
apocalypse when he became war I think it
was but again I mean he's null and he's
basically called the breaker of worlds
because what in the hell else would you
call him everybody loves world breaker
Hulk but again it's kind of cool because
from here we basically pick up with a
character named titania now the
character of titania made her debut back
in Secret Wars issue number three the
original Secret Wars from 1984 the
original Secret Wars was a highly
publicized story so because of that the
idea was that if so many people are
gonna be reading this story then not
only was the basis of it to bring like
all the heroes and villains together and
have them face off against each other in
an effort to sell toys but why not add
some new characters in there and so what
we got a couple different people there
we got Jennifer Carpenter who was the
original Spider Woman but then we also
got titania Mary McFerrin Namira
McFerrin was not really interesting up
until that point in fact her origin
story was pretty mundane she was raised
in the suburbs of Denver she was shy she
was timid and never really had anything
going for the idea was that during the
events of secret Wars before Doctor Doom
had stole the power of Galactus and then
eventually the power of the Beyonder
what he had done was he had basically
created kind of like a super villain
team trying to recruit people to his
side and so what ended up happening here
is that doom discovered a Mary and
another character and I can't remember
her name like Vanessa I think it was and
then in turn basically endowed them with
powers now Mary was endowed with
basically super strength durability
different things like that and she was
also like grown in size so she became a
lot more
I'm Xuan and she became a lot like a lot
stronger a lot more muscular than her
previous version had been now after the
events of seiga Wars he kind of had an
on-again off-again relationship with
crusher creel which basically became
more solidified by the mid-1990s and so
by that point going forward they were
just kind of together but from there
like what is up happening she's one of
the people who basically seizes a hammer
for herself it crashes she grabs it
picks it up and then she tells absorbing
man you have a hammer waiting on you and
this is kind of a big deal because
pressure creel is someone who can
basically absorb various metals and turn
himself into those metals absorb their
properties and so in turn giving him a
hammer I would argue he could
potentially be one of the most powerful
now we'll find out as time goes on but
it's not as somewhat of a cool thing
because in this moment with all of the
chair all the worthy basically being
selected or a huge a number of them
being selected essentially the serpent's
starts reaching out to all of them and
saying your job now is to basically fill
the world with chaos to seed as much
chaos destruction and fear as you
possibly can and when that's done we'll
take the next step and that's exactly
what they do they start ripping through
and tearing things up now this fear
spreads more fear I mean the Incredible
Hulk running through ripping things to
pieces red she hope doing what you can
is instilling as much fear as possible
because now you have all these people
with this these insane levels of
strength and power who are just running
rampant across the face of the earth and
where the avengers try to respond the
problem with this is that their
communications network is essentially
taken down when the White House and the
Capitol are totally obliterated and so
where Captain America kind of sends out
the SOS and says Avengers Assemble
there's no one there to respond no one
answers him and so essentially
everyone's kind of scattered to the four
winds it's pandemonium it's it's a
worst-case situation it's pretty messed
up and it's pretty rough but it's
amazing wood that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to come as explain it make
sure you guys with the sub button to
become part of the robb for if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]